[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci alors
merci Audrey merci d'avoir été là je
sais que c'était pas facile merci merci
pour remercie pour nous merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir été merci
il est heureux
Alex
la chaîne bordel
allez
[Rires]
on va dire
d'ici parce que après viens pas me
demander des conseils pour faire de
l'audience dans les couloirs
[Applaudissements]
tu sais quoi tu sais ce qui va se passer
qu'est-ce qui va se passer hier j'ai
j'appelle j'appelle pas attends
je t'appelle je t'appelle ça passait
quand vous devez m'appeler vous dites
j'appelle j'appelle pas non parce qu'on
sait que si je te dis ne le dis pas tu
es comme Amanda Lear quand la lumière
s'allume tu t'allume avec et tu peux pas
t'empêcher de dire les choses bah vas-y
dis-moi un secret tu vois je le répète
après moi
[Rires]
je suis pas quelqu'un de tu veux me dire
un secret toi vas-y
je te jure ok par contre tu me touches
pas trop
c'est un coup de froid vas-y dépêche-toi
parce que tu vas le voir un coup de
chaud tu vois il y a des petits yeux
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi ça m'est sorti tout seul tu
m'as tu m'as pas dit qu'il fallait pas
répéter redis-moi un autre truc non non
[Rires]
même moi un peu moins
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà tu as
compris là ça je dirais pas allez vas-y
voilà voilà voilà voilà c'est important
[Rires]
je crois pas du tout exactement
[Applaudissements]